What's up, buddy? Hello, brother Sam.
How are you? What's up?
How are you, brother? I'm doing good.
How are you doing? I'm well.
What? Hello, Sam. Yeah, Sam. Okay, now
go ahead. Okay, you can hear me now.
Okay, good. Uh Sam, thank you for taking
my call. I was uh just wondering
regarding the word uh
Yes.
Oh, let me tell people to question this.
Hold on. Uh, because I've already
answered this in the past. This brother
heard, was it a Catholic priest or who
was it? No, it was a YouTube video
during Eastern Mass. They were Eastern
Mass. Okay. So, it was the priests, the
bishops in an Eastern Mass. the Easter
mass in Latin that he heard this video
where the priests and the bishops
referred to
Lucifer. That means the Catholics,
they're offering the mass to
Lucifer. Oh
no, that's proof the Pope is
Antichrist. Now, you ready for me to
destroy that stupid argument?
Absolutely. These arguments, dude,
they're some of the stupidest arguments
I've heard in my life. Okay. Number
one, Isaiah 14:12, the word Lucifer,
that's a Latin term. You know that,
right? Yes. And you know that day storm.
Okay. But you know that Isaiah 14:12,
it's not written in Latin, right? It's
written
in Hebrew, right? Okay. Okay. Okay, the
Hebrew word is hal benshakar hal, right?
Shining one, son of the
morning. Number two, the word
Lucifer is a generic term to refer to
something or someone that shines because
the same Latin Bible uses a term Lucifer
for believers.
Second Peter
1:19. Okay, let me show it to you.
But what's it in Latin?
What is 2 Peter 1:19 in Latin?
The word Lucifer appears a few times. It
says when the when the day star comes
into your heart. Okay, that and what's
the word in Latin there? Lucifer. So
Lucifer is going to come into your
heart. So he's going to come and dwell
in your hearts and you're going to
belong to Satan, right? It's absurd. So
you so you you yourself you left.
Yeah. Right here. Let me get you. It's
it's tradition, you know, this tradition
that Satan is Lucifer, but but also this
this word Lucifer seems to apply to
Jesus if you really look at the New
Testament. Well, that's one of the
arguments that King James only advocates
and here's the link guys. King James
only advocates they say see if you
translate Isaiah 14:12 like the NIV does
morning star son of the dawn well in
Isaiah 14:12 the morning star is Satan
and Revelation 22:16 Jesus says he's the
morning star so the NIV makes Jesus
Satan oh my goodness Luciferian Bible
versions all right you're laughing at me
too bro you're hurting my feelings
No, I'm just kidding. Right. That's
true. But you got it right now. I I just
gave you guys the link. There's the link
to the Latin Vulgate and the English
translation of Second Peter 1:19. You
don't need to read Latin because Latin
is spelled with English letters. Right
here it is. You'll see 2 Peter 1:19
where it says, "Until the day dawn, the
day star arise in your hearts." Now look
at it. It says at Lucifer or
Cordibus at Lucifer or so Lucifer is
going to rise in your hearts according
to Peter. So when the Lord
returns at the end of the age, one of
the signs of his coming is Satan's going
to dwell in your hearts and you're going
to be happy and rejoicing for it. Happy,
happy, joy, joy.
You see how stupid that argument is?
Yes. So there you go. It's so stupid,
dude. Where did this tradition of Satan
and Lucifer, is it just King James? Is
that mistransation? No, it it's prior to
the King James. Let me tell you where
the word Lucifer has been associated
with Satan. Isaiah
14:12-15 has been
typically been interpreted as referring
to the fall of Satan as well as Ezekiel
28:11-19. So if you ask a Christian,
where do you find a reference to the
fall of Satan? What was Satan and why
did he fall? What was his sin? People
will say Isaiah
14:12-15 and Ezekiel 28 11-19. So once
you believe that Isaiah
14:12-15 is about Satan and then you use
the King James version because it's not
a King James invention. Even some of the
English Bibles before the King James,
they had Lucifer there. So now if you
take Isaiah 14:12 as was about Satan and
you see that in your English Bible
because for over 300 years the King
James Bible was the chief Bible for
English-speaking Christians and it says
Lucifer. So then you're going to connect
Lucifer as Satan's name,
right? when in reality Lucifer is simply
the Latin translation of
hal the Hebrew word which means shining
one because think about it if you really
assume Satan's name is Lucifer are you
saying that God gave Satan a Latin name
before the creation of Adam and
Eve so that God was speaking Latin
right you see how silly that is it's
it's incredibly silly Right. I mean,
think about it. There's a lot of
traditions that that we believe that are
that aren't based on any facts. Yeah.
And even if you want to say confuses a
lot of people. Exactly. Even if you want
to say Isaiah 14 is about Satan. And now
Lucifer has become a popular name for
Satan. So Satan adopts it to deceive
people like Lucifer. The Luciferians,
they always luciferian agenda this.
Yeah. Yeah. So I have no problem with
that. What I have a problem with with is
assuming Lucifer can only be used of
Satan. Because if you're really going to
be consistent, second Peter 1:19 says,
"The morning star, the day star is going
to rise in your heart. So Lucifer is
going to reign in your heart."
Blasphemy. But more than that, why in
the world would God give Satan a Latin
name? Because Satan became Satan right
after the creation of Adam and Eve,
right?
Uh yes. So are you telling me that?
because this is his name before he fell.
So, are you telling me that God was
speaking Latin to Satan?
Right. Latin wasn't even invented. It
wasn't even Well, we're going to have to
do a Muslim thing and say Latin is the
language of heaven. They say Arabic, but
we're going to say Latin. Okay. So,
Latin is the language of heaven. So they
were speaking Latin in heaven and then
somehow Latin got lost and got
supplanted by other languages like
Hebrew, Aramaic or even Phoenician until
it was rediscovered thanks
to the expansion of Rome.
Correct. So thanks to Ramalus because I
I was told that Rome is named after
Raml. So he must be the true messenger
of Allah. la rless
rasool. But we got to say that in Latin.
But anyway, I hope that answered that
nonsense. Sam, I just wanted to thank
you as well because I came out of
Adventism and uh it's a horrible
deceptive religion and uh also because
of the the Catholic communion
uh I was I mean there was a lot of
physical healings the first time I I
part par parttook of the Eucharist. I
was healed of a lot of uh fibromyalgia
and glory to God. People don't
understand this how powerful this is.
Glory to God. But glory to God, he did
that miracle for you. And so now that
guy who did that video, yeah. Uh I don't
know what to say. I'd like to have him
on and say, "So wait, Lucifer, the
Catholics are offering God forbid such
blasphemy, the Eucharist. Lucifer, God
forbid. So that means Peter is saying
that Lucifer is going to reign in my
heart." And then I would like to spit on
them and then repent, you know. Yes,
it's absolutely true. Silly, stupid.
Well, and there was another guy made a
video saying that Jesus
is that he's Satan. It was just came a
giant rabbit hole. Yeah, that's how it
works. That's how Satan because you see
one thing people love they love to think
they have some secret special knowledge
of the Bible and languages no one else
does because that feeds their ego and
makes them feel important when in
reality that's a satanic scheme to
inflate your ego and make you feel like
you're superior in intellect and
spiritual piety than the next guy when
in reality this is his ploy of
destroying you and severing you from the
body of Christ because knowledge puffs
up. Paul says 1 Corinthians 8:1, but
love builds. In other words, if the
knowledge I pursue is to truly know God
and love him and be loved by him, one of
the signs of that knowledge is I won't
use my knowledge to bash you and beat
you and make myself look better than
you, but I'll use that love to build you
up to be more like Jesus and fall more
in love with Jesus and get closer to
Christ. That's the true goal of
attaining knowledge.
Amen. Right, brother? Absolutely right.
So, brother, if you have more questions,
call me. I got two more calls and I'll
be wrapping it up. So, Lord bless you
and praise God for that miracle. Now,
you have no excuse for turning away. God
miraculously confirmed to you the saving
benefits and power of the Eucharist
because he wanted to give you a sign to
assure you you're going to be attacked.
People are going to try to deceive you
from the path like this video that you
saw. But rest
assured, you are on the right path. Keep
yielding to the spirit. Keep trusting
the
spirit. And you're in good hands. So,
glory to God.
All right, brother. Take care, man. Love
you in the Lord. Love you, too, brother.
Take care, man. Good question. Excellent
question,